can you steal man the case that hal 9000
from space odyssey
was doing the right thing
so you know so for people who haven't
seen 2001 space odyssey hell 9000 is a
very kind of
um
focused on the mission cares a lot about
the mission and uh kind of
wants to hurt the astronauts that try to
get in the way of the mission
i think he was doing who's program to do
which was just to follow the mission
but didn't have a sense of
you know i think a broader
duty you could i mean
what's the broader duty exactly uh
maintaining the the well-being of
astronauts yeah or giving them another
option i think you viewed them as like
completely
expendable rather than say not
completely
it's a trade-off well
so like a doctor has to make decisions
like this too
you're restricted
on the resources you have to make life
and death decisions yeah so
maybe hal 9000 had a long-term vision of
what is good for the civilization back
at home maybe a a deontogenic vision of
what was the best duty uh for for the
genetics you could say
it's de-antogenic it's a word i made up
in the book it's like what is your
genetic duties
when you think of my your dna right what
are you supposed to do with it which is
kind of the value of life but if hal was
a silicon-based version of genetics
which is just his own
maintenance of himself and self-survival
you could argue he's doing the right
thing for himself but i think
a human in that circumstance might have
tried to find a way to
even if the astronauts don't agree with
the mission to figure out something to
get them on a different spacecraft to go
away or something versus just say well
you're in the way of the mission i'll
just you have to die is i think uh but
accommodation counters you made to your
point with doctors like sometimes you'd
like to save three people but you can
only save two yeah and you have to at
some point pick but i think
that since it's a false dichotomy i
think hal
didn't wasn't programmed to and didn't
try to find a third solution
perhaps the 62 russell proposes this
idea that
ai systems should have self-doubt they
should be always uncertain in their
final decision and that would help hal
sort of get out of the local
the local optimum of this this is the
mission like always be a little bit like
not sure if this is the right thing and
then you're forced to kind of contend
with other humans with other entities
and what is the right decision
um so like the the worst stuff the worst
thing about decisions from that
perspective
is uh if you're extremely confident and
you're stubborn and immovable
right and then but it's programming
doubt is that sounds complicated that
sounds like you can go wrong yes
you can go wrong either way if you're
too confident
you won't see the other options if you
have too much doubt you won't move
you'll be paralyzed by the options so
you need some middle ground which i
think is what most people experience
every day is
we all love the concept of being a
steadfast
resolute leader making big decisions
quickly and without question
but at the same time we know people can
be blinded to things they're missing if
they're if they're too headstrong so so
how would you improve hell 9000
i think i i would
include other because hal is one program
much like we do for humans you get
feedback from other humans before you
make a decision that affects all of them
so i think
hal could have gotten feedback from
other ai systems that said well is this
are there other options here and done it
probably very quickly or you can even
you know embed a programming system
where the ai has a primary function but
at times of uncertainty queries a series
of other programmed ai's to ask for a
consensus almost i'm like a democracy of
the ai
but since it's all programmed you can
bring it all together and say there's a
primary but it only activates the
parliament if you will for a decision
when needed
now i don't know how you program
dramatically different ais all in one
system that are different enough but
yeah conceptually it's possible of
course that can lead to you know log jam
and government parliament doesn't do
anything or congress doesn't do anything
yeah so
there's trade-offs but
it's one idea
i i you know i'm sorry dave i'm afraid i
can't do that that i'm really i find
really compelling the idea
i'd love to set that up in my own life
at some point is um
so you're stuck there on a spaceship
yeah with an ai system
and it's just the two of you and you
have to figure it out i love that
challenge
i love that um
almost a really
deep human conflict
of through conversation have to arrive
at something you you really try to
understand what survival is at stake you
have to try to understand the other
being now you think it's just the robot
we keep saying like it's just programmed
but you know what when you talk to
another human it's just a bag of meat
you know and then and then you disagree
and you're like
you know everybody starts using terms
like how dumb can you be how ignorant
can you be yeah come on this is the
right way what are you talking about
this is you're what you're talking about
is insane and when the stakes go up when
it's life and death you have to convince
another person first you have to
understand another person in this cave
case you have to understand the machine
the other the machine
without knowing how it was programmed
because
yeah as a programmer even i mean this is
very much true for the for these legged
robots i really make sure that
everything is that's programmed
um is sufficiently large and has a
sufficient degree of uncertainty where
i'm constantly surprised i don't know
how it works i kind of know how it works
but i'm surprised constantly and there
there's a human
component of trying to figure each other
out and if it's high stakes
life and death through conversation i
mean to me that's actually what makes a
great companion out in space it's like
you're both in charge of each other's
life
and you both don't quite know
how each other works
and also
you don't
treat each other as a servant
so
i don't know if hal
hal was treated that way a little bit
where
you're like yeah like a servant as
opposed to a friend a companion
a teammate you know um
because i think
the the worst part about treating an ai
system or or another human being as a
servant is what it does to you if you
treat them as a means to an end rather
than end in of itself then you've
debased them and and like lessen the
humanity in yourself yeah at the same
time which is which is i mean that's why
they talked about kids have to be polite
to alexa
um because they find if they're you know
if people are if kids are rude to ai
systems they actually that
it's a bad sign right it's it's a bad
sign and it develops the wrong thing in
terms of how they treat other
human beings